citizens of Gotham Batman is once again
coming to bust some bad guys and it
sounds like the latest iteration of the
Caped Crusader will be more conflicted
than ever at least us a word from the
actor who's set to Don the cape and cowl
and the upcoming superhero flick the
Batman Robert Pattinson recently sat
down with the New York Times Kyle
Buchanan who took the opportunity to ask
Pattinson about his role as a Dark
Knight in the soon to shoot Batman movie
the actor was quick to praise director
Matt Reeves and offered his own read of
a notoriously complex superhero he's
about to play he gushed I loved the
director Matt Reeves and it's a dope
character his morality is a little off
he's not the golden boy unlike almost
every other comic book character there
is a simplicity to his worldview but
where it's it's it's strange which
allows you to have more scope with the
character the actor then revealed why he
was drawn to the character and in doing
so he made a head-turning comment about
Batman
Pattinson said Batman's not a hero he's
a complicated character I don't think I
could ever play a real hero there's
always got to be something a little bit
wrong by the sounds of it Pattinson and
Reeves are apparently aiming to take the
hero out of the superhero genre with the
Batman which is some of the most
intriguing news we've heard about the
new movie thus far that's saying a lot
in a week that's also seen the Batman
cast zoe kravitz a Selina Kyle
aka Catwoman and set its sights on Paul
Dano as a Riddler
all of that came just weeks after it was
reported that Westworld star Jeffrey
Wright was in talks to appear as
Batman's Gotham City Police Department
Ally Commissioner Gordon though we've
got to admit that it's initially
shocking to hear Pattinson say that
Batman isn't a hero it's not exactly an
earth-shattering revelation to learn
that the actor and director Matt Reeves
plan to subvert the norm that vision was
first teased with the news that reused
for scrapping Ben Affleck script for the
Batman and furthered when Affleck
himself was relieved of his dark watch
over the streets of Gotham
in spite of its initial production
turmoil the Batman soldier done with
Reeves at the helm though months pass
with little to no news of what the
director had in mind the silence finally
broke earlier this year when Ruiz
revealed that his movie would be a quote
point-of-view driven the why Batman tale
that sees Batman flexing his detective
skills at most films of barely touched
on at the time Reeves told The Hollywood
Reporter I hope it's going to be a story
that will be thrilling but also
emotional it's more Batman in his
detective mode than we've seen in the
films it's going to allow his character
to have an arc so that he can go through
a transformation when it was announced
that Pattinson haven't up to done the
mask in the Batman the internet nearly
imploded at the news with the actor
himself even fearing the wrath of an
insolent Internet fandom well most of
those fans were intrigued by the
thoughts of Pattinson in the Batsuit
there were plenty who were wary of the
former Twilight a throb bringing the
requisite charm and Menace required with
the dual roles of Bruce Wayne and Batman
but funds have little to worry about
Pattinson has spent his post twilight
years forging a reputation as one of the
most fiercely devoted and adventurous
actors on the planet a reputation he's
earned by delivering show-stopping
performances in Indy fare like
Cosmopolis good time high life and the
just release film the lighthouse though
the Batman will serve as the highest
profile film Pattinson has appeared in
in years this little doll the actor will
bring the same sort of intensity to his
role as a Dark Knight sadly it'll be a
while before we see what comes from its
enticing approach to the role the Batman
will begin filming in early 2020 but
won't be out in theaters until June 25th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
but your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail said you don't miss a single
one
[Music]